souvent le gadget est un jouet et nous
avons cru remarquer que ceux qui font
vendre chaque semaine un journal de
jeunes sont très souvent d'inspiration
scientifique
aussi avons nous interroger les
inventeurs de ces amusements éphémère
quand vous êtes je crois des
spécialistes incontestés du gadget est
bien souvent l'impression que les tels
que vous retenez sont des thèmes
scientifiques est ce qu'il faut en
conclure que le thème scientifique est
même quitter beaucoup d'enfants oui
absolument
nous nous dirigeons d'ailleurs de plus
en plus et nous avons commencé de
l'archerie gadget qui sont disons-le
explication concrète le phénomène
naturel de leçons qui touche aussi bien
la biologie que la physique par exemple
le premier gros succès gadgets c'était
justement un succès biologique c'était
la poudre de vie oui nous avions rêvé
depuis longtemps d'avoir une une poudre
qu'on pourrions mettre dans l'eau pour
avoir un animal vivant fin c'était un
rêve
nous avons cherché pendant plus d'une
année ce n'est plus un rêve
la poudre merveilleuse existe le
détective du gadget ont découverte en
californie
c'est tout simplement la forme
déshydratée de ce petit animal appelé
artémias salines promis dans l'eau il
retrouve comme ici sa forme et manifeste
sa vie autre conquête des sciences
naturelles au service du cac jette ses
pois sauteurs qui s'agitent sans fin
comme mû par une force magique
en fait ce ne sont que de petites
prisons à l'intérieur desquelles ce
débat une chenille
sa maison est ce qu'on pouvait ce qu'on
peut trouver comme ça dix millions de
fois sauteur parce que je pense il n'y a
pas
on ne cultive pas le pois sauteurs
seront effectives le blé ou la betterave
non c'est une plante sauvage qui
voulaient qui ne pousse que dans le nord
du mexique dans l'état de la sono et
disons que celui qu'on appelle le roi
des pois sauteurs réunis au mois de
juillet août tous les indiens yaki
maillot de la région et qui vont de
fourrer en four et parce que ce sont des
petits bosquets et sur une étendue
presque 800 kilomètres carrés et qui
vont cueillir je peux dire ou ramasser
du pois sauteurs qui ont éclaté pour
donner ce fruit est il et centralise
quelquefois ils les vendent en touriste
mais c'est la première fois qu'il a fait
qu'il a récolté je peux dire une un
nombre aussi considérable puisque de
coutume ils en recueillent à peu près
deux millions par an qui sont vendus aux
touristes aux frontières du mexique
vous demandez combien vous avez et dix
millions dix millions dix millions de
fois sauteurs enfin nous en avons
utilisé 5 millions environ et nous avons
eu 5 millions ici pour d autres émotions
qui sautent dans la cas actuellement
le gadget savant n'est pourtant pas une
exclusivité des sciences de la vie
l'astronautique y trouve aussi sa place
cette lune a certes une forme qui
dérouterait les astronomes mais dans le
détail sa topographie est exact ainsi
que la position des sites d'alunissage
enfin les expériences du physique
amusante permettent à cette toupie
magnétique de dompter un serpent de
métal et les courants d'air chaud sont
mis à profit pour animer cet hélicoptère
de cartons
et cette fusée un nom cette fusée à
l'epo tic mais c'est une vraie fusée
c'est à dire que elle contient sa propre
énergie qui est un carburant qui
mélangés à l'eau produit une forte
pression et projets de la fusée à 200 x
server suivant ces carburants alors le
quart d'heure après c'est un mini secret
mais c'est un secret tout de même
[Musique]